today i've got two fantastic news beans
in the news pod it's co-host of cbs
mornings the lovely neighbor listen
how are you doing i am freaking out to
be next to you i'll get into that yeah
and obviously the co-host of drew's news
right here every day my anchor ross mack
can we just say how excited we are that
you are here today i i am a huge
seahawks fan
that's what i'm talking about
i know ross you love football every
every sunday you want to hang out you
want to go let's do it okay we're going
to get in the fantasy league together
okay
i'm a little worried my fantasy league
might be different than yours though
okay
what fantasy are we talking about yeah
exactly nate that's what i was doing
i think when it comes to football your
fantasies i mean they might align
actually obviously if we could go out
and just toss the football around on
like 57th street could you ever do that
let's do that 100 okay stay tuned so now
we have a date i got to come back okay
we're good with that i'm just so glad
you're here in the first place because i
bragged to my kids about this you would
think i was like
girls
i am getting to get to
co-anchor cbs morning news and they were
like
and i am there and i'm watching you nate
and i'm
literally like this is the biggest star
this is a star thank you star star star
and i was talking to shauna the producer
and i was like i mean i can't take my
eyes off him he has just got it he is a
star
and obviously she knew something that
she couldn't tell me at the time but
then it was announced that you are the
co-host permanently
and
cbs mornings is just on fire and i'm
just so glad that you're
a huge part of that um because you
really are you can't take your eyes off
of you you're so good
i want to stay here i like this company
yeah you should but no no i i appreciate
that and i'm just part of the team and
it's not just uh gail tony and i
we have a long list of men and women um
that have come before us and that are
working with us now and sometimes the
world can seem a bit chaotic and
sometimes the news can pull you down a
little bit but what we do is we give you
the news and we give you it in a way
that you are equipped to take on the
world but then also we will uplift you
we will make you smile and give you
something that you can feel like you can
take on the rest of your day with uh
that's what we do on cbs mornings we
could use a little bit of that thank you
for that
thank you to cbs morning that's right
thank you thank you thank you well shall
we get into some news oh let's do it
let's get into some news all right okay
this one's a fun one and i think like
maiden tailored for you nate it's scary
movie season that's right it's halloween
um that is the vision of a middle-aged
white woman cracking herself
um
and we have got big questions for horror
fans can an indie horror movie be just
as scary as one with a huge budget the
new york post reports that a company
called finance buzz is gonna test this
they're hiring a horror heart rate
analyst to watch 13 scary movies across
all budgets while wearing heart rate
monitors
i know i love this the movies range from
a paranormal activity which cost 15 000
to make it's a good one to a quiet place
too which cost 60 million
all right nate yes
thoughts i love horror movies
i'm all in you guys love horror movies
got a couple snaps up there yeah
i feel like uh fear is something we
don't tap into enough you know i love a
good jump out scare when you're walking
down the hallway i love a good haunted
house no um you know who you don't want
to be sitting um in front of in a horror
movie ross matthews okay because
it's not for me i'd rather watch bridges
in madison county a hundred times than
one horror movie
give me steel magnolia
you ha you think the movie's scary wait
till you hear me shriek behind you not
good no listen there's nothing like
watching a movie so scary that you got
to watch cartoons before you go to bed
i'm talking about a movie so scary now
that when you take out the trash at
night you run full speed back to the
house because you know
[Applause]
all right we have you here you look
amazing so we have to talk about a
fashion comeback all right now barrymore
you are at the cutting edge of this one
take a look the new york times reports
that the sweater vest oh she back and
this time she is sexy check this out
shawn mendes harry styles
dwayne johnson
all rocking a sexy mess
now drew
i actually looked at the show and i
noticed you have on occasion worn a
sweater vest on this show
[Applause]
and i think the audience just voted you
vest dressed oh yeah okay i'm actually
i'm wearing one today
too
um for women wearing vests um
my chest can look like two egg mcmuffins
in
a vest so i gotta be careful you gotta
choose that vest really widely wisely
um
it's true though now listen i'm not
exactly what you would call a boob man
so i don't get it
but egg mcmuffin drew just like weird it
just it can make you it can give you an
odd shape as a woman egg mcmuffins are
very popular so
i'm just throwing it out there
i don't even know how neat you're gonna
transition to the next story i love a
good sweater vest yeah um i rock sweater
vest look at that that's me
[Applause]
you see that
you know you're such a fashionable man
you have a whole
like suit situation
and well i got my legs out right now
what
no sorry i didn't mean to show my egg
mcmuffins
[Applause]
and put that away that's like medieval
times like turkey like oh my god
situation
a little seriousness up top party on the
bottom i love it
what was the catalyst
for fashion for you because you have a
line of suits you have many pairs of
shoes you collect
what what where did that sort of impetus
get born i've always felt like um what
we put on our exterior says a lot about
who we are and how we feel about
ourselves and and i wanted to create a
clothing line that was affordable that
was fresh and fly that a young man who
didn't have a ton of money in his pocket
could buy so he can look good when he's
doing his thing oh no
come on
oh my god
i love you
oh
obsessed crew you guys gonna make me cry
up in here well um it's happened before
[Music]